1923 is shrouded in secrecy. But to all the
Yellowstone fans waiting for a glimpse into
the latest installment of the Dutton family
saga, here's everything we know so far.
According to The Hollywood Reporter,
1923 was commissioned following the
success of both Yellowstone and 1883,
all but confirming that Paramount+ sees
Taylor Sheridan's tapestry of family
and power as a flagship franchise.
"That land is mine, and no
one can sell it but me."
THR had previously suggested that 1883 wouldreceive an additional batch of episodes but
Sheridan has since corrected the
record, clarifying to Deadline,
In 1923, we'll see the early years of
the 20th century throw life-altering
curveballs at the Dutton family. The
series promises to be an insightful
look at Yellowstone ranch's humble beginnings.
Taylor Sheridan's 1923 will debut
on December 18, 2022 on Paramount+
in the U.S. and Canada. Viewers in the U.K. andAustralia can catch the episode on December 19.
"There's a rawness to the west that
still reflects where we came from."
The premiere will also run on cable's ParamountNetwork immediately following Episode 7 of the
latest season of Yellowstone. The secondepisode of 1923 will hit the Paramount
Network on January 1, 2023. It remains to be seenif the rest of 1923 will air on the cable channel.
1923 will consist of eight episodes and
is expected to run for two seasons. It's
not known if both seasons will take placein 1923, or if there will be a time jump.
Like Yellowstone and 1883, Taylor Sheridan'supcoming prequel series will focus on the
infamous Dutton family as they continue to expandtheir reach and power in the state of Montana.
"You know, the first Duttons to settle
this valley, fighting was all they knew.
It's how they got here. How they
kept the land once they did."
This time, the Dutton ancestors include
Jacob Dutton, the grizzled old patriarch
of the Yellowstone ranch. Jacob is the
brother of James, who was played by Tim
McGraw in 1883. Jacob Dutton is joined onscreen by his loyal, headstrong wife Cara.
1923 explores the early days of the Yellowstone,
making it abundantly clear that John DuttonIII and his family have it easy compared to
the challenges their ancestors faced. Viewerswill experience some of the 20th century's key
events through the eyes of the Duttons.
An official plot synopsis confirmed that,
1923 will be the most star-studded seriesin the Yellowstone universe to date.
"You ever wonder what this
place looked like before any
of us were here?"
"All the time."
The show is led by Harrison Ford, who is makinghis television debut as Jacob Dutton. In a Vanity
Fair interview, Ford describes Jacob as a manwho has no choice but to focus on survival.
Ford went on to describe the
Dutton struggles, saying:
"What an embarrassment we are to the
sacrifice it took to give us a home."
Helen Mirren plays Cara Dutton, Jacob's wife. Byall accounts, the two seem to still be in love,
even after 40 years of marriage. But while Jacobis the archetype of the all-American cowboy,
Cara is more nuanced. Mirren's Cara speakswith an Irish accent. She told Vanity Fair,
Other 1923 cast members include Supernaturalactor Sebastian Roché as Father Renaud,
the principal of a Native American school. TheDeparted actor James Badge Dale plays Jacob's
right-hand man, John Dutton Sr. John's
wife Emma is played by Marley Shelton,
last seen in 2022's Scream. Robert Patrick, whorecently played the White Dragon in Peacemaker,
will play Sheriff William McDowell.
And rounding out the cast is Timothy
Dalton as Donald Whitfield, playing a characterdescribed only as "intimidating and nefarious."
There's a brief teaser trailer for 1923
that clocks in at just under 30 seconds.
This first look at the series paints early
20th century Montana as an unforgiving state.
The trailer kicks off with an
unidentified female narrator saying,
"Violence has always haunted this family."
She goes on to say violence has followedthe Dutton family all the way "from the
Scottish highlands and the slums of Dublin."
A young man is seen fallen off his horse,reaching for a gun. Then soldiers fill the screen,
making it clear that war will feature in thestory. World War I ended five years earlier,
in 1918, but was surely not far from
the memories of its veterans. 1883
fans will remember Tom Hanks' cameo
in a Civil War flashback on that show.
Viewers catch a glimpse of a dour JacobDutton on horseback. And more battle
scenes are intercut with shots of Jacob,
wearing a sheriff's star, and the rest of
the Dutton clan together. Helen Mirren's CaraDutton is a fighter, too. She's seen bloodied,
pointing a shotgun at someone cowering on theground. From the looks of things, 1923 is going
to be just as suspenseful and action-packed
as 1883, in true Taylor Sheridan style.
Those who want to catch up on Taylor
Sheridan's Yellowstone franchise before
the debut of 1923 may need to subscribe to avariety of streaming services. Yellowstone,
the heart of the franchise, is currently
airing its fifth season on Paramount Network,
with new episodes released weekly in the U.S.Seasons 1 to 4 can be watched on Peacock.
Viewers who want to stream Season 5 can do sovia the Paramount Network. Fans can also catch
up on the series via DirecTV if you want to catchall those lighthearted Beth moments we all love.
"I believe in loving with your whole soul.
And destroying anything that
wants to kill what you love."
In Canada, Seasons 1 to 4 of Yellowstone areavailable to stream on Amazon Prime Video,
and Season 5 episodes are released weekly.All 5 seasons of Yellowstone are available on
Paramount+ in the United Kingdom. Viewers fromaround the world can also purchase individual
seasons through their favorite digital services,like Apple TV, the Google Play Store, and Amazon.
1883 is available to stream on Paramount+ whereverthe service is available, including the U.S.,
Canada, and the U.K, and now is a perfect timeto catch up on the drama before 1923 arrives.